on this episode of traveled air I'm
taking Caroline to nurture by nature
where we are gonna swim with otters and
I'm here at Pony land to take Joe on a
beautiful horseback ride in the ocean
come join us on our adventures on this
episode of Travel dares
[Music]
welcome to travel dears I'm Caroline and
I'm Joe and we're here in San Diego we
left New York so inspired to travel and
now we're here to take on a new
adventure all right Caroline ready for
your first clue ready let's do this get
ready to make some fun okay okay let's
make some friends this is perfect for
Caroline I know she's never done
anything like this and she is going to
freak out for now we're on the platform
so remove your blindfold because right
now we are swimming with our words
[Applause]
I am so excited I've never been this
excited in my entire life to do anything
the otters that we're gonna be swimming
with today are Asian small-clawed otters
raised by Wendy my wife and she's kind
of the otter mama everything we do here
is pretty much voluntary for the otters
and it's all about making it fun for the
otters firstly and then secondly fun for
the people of the 13 species of otters
in the world 12 are endangered or
threatened and it's happening extremely
quickly
so if we can endear you guys and the
public to otters and make them care
they'll help to save these animals in
the wild so what did you think of your
travel day I have been smiling this
whole time my face hurts
I have not smelled like this in a long
time so I'm so happy we came here not
only was this so much fun but we learned
so much and that's why it's so rewarding
absolutely
I had an amazing time are you ready for
your adventure I cannot wait I'm so
ready here is your clue all right here
we go prepare for a thrilling ride oh
man what does that mean so excited I
can't wait to see what you have this is
going to be an experience of a lifetime
one two are you ready take your
blindfold off
horse
[Music]
all right let's get saddled up so we
have about 40 head of horses here at San
Diego Beach rides the horses are kind of
like you know dogs either they really
like water they really don't so we pick
the horses that love the water and then
we will send them out with you on your
swim adventure ride it's a great week to
see southern San Diego I'm so stoked I
love horseback riding and I've never
done it in the ocean I don't even think
that was an option that sounds
incredible I cannot wait to do this
[Music]
riding to the beach hey Joe I think I
can hear the waves and must be close
Joe's view is insane this is beautiful
oh here we go
whoa the very surreal feeling to be on
the beach with the horse just
experiencing the waves and the wind and
the horses just it's very peaceful I
think we're gonna go deeper into the
water this was an unforgettable
experience
so honestly this is what traveling is so
incredible everybody knows San Diego has
some of the most beautiful beaches in
the world but we got to experience two
different sides that not a lot of people
know about out of five stars how would
you rate me five stars when you took up
the blindfold and saw those otters your
response was priceless okay Caroline
more importantly how would you rate me
out of five I'm gonna give you a 3.5 we
got a five you're kidding me you know
you don't want to go deeper into the
water you know what Joe you seem a
little hurt from that rating so drinks
on me yes you are gonna get a five out
of five on our next activity I know what
I feel it you know what 40.5 rating I'm
kicking it up a notch for Austin all
right cheers to our next adventure
[Music]